[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
première étape dans l'aménagement de la
rente entre Saint-Malo et Dinard là où
la marée fait pénétrer et redescendre
180 millions de mètres cubes d'eau de
mer l'estuaire de la Rance vient d'être
fermée par le barrage provisoire à
l'abri duquel cédera la première usine
marée motrice des 6 Pertuis de
régularisation sur la rive droite à
l'écluse sur la rive gauche la ligne des
gabillons est maintenant continue
derrière la rince est devenue un lac
[Musique]
les ouvriers viennent d'achever la
consolidation des derniers gabions qui
ont bouclé l'estuaire ces cylindres
creux aux parois métalliques qu'on a
enfonce dans l'eau et dont on assure
ensuite la stabilité en y versant un
mélange de sable et d'eau l'eau
s'échappe le sable reste
et c'est la phase la plus délicate des
travaux qui est maintenant achevée et il
appartient au plongeur de vérifier
l'étanchéité de l'édifice
sur la rive gauche les deux ponts
mobiles en position levée sont déjà en
place il permettront d'assurer la
liaison routière d'une rive à l'autre en
faisant franchir l'écluse aménagé pour
la navigation une écluse de 13 mètres de
large sur 65 de noms
il reste à construire un deuxième
barrage provisoire derrière le premier
assécher entre les deux barrages pour
enfin édifier à pied sec l'usine au 24
turbines grâce auxquelles les marées
pourront produire 560 millions de
kilowatts heure il faudra encore
attendre 1966 pour voir la fin de ce
nouveau travail d'Hercule le premier du
genre dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis le Cercle militaire dont il ne
reste que quelques arches jusqu'au
quartier les plus extrêmes scopin est
aujourd'hui qu'un tas de ruines
maintenant que tout espoir d'arracher
encore une vie au décompte a disparu on
peut mieux établir le bilan de cette
catastrophe qui dépasse en ampleur la
plupart de celles qui ont endeuillé ces
derniers 20 ans
les deuils à scopier se comptent par
sans tête pour un survivant sauvé qu'on
vient de cadavres restent encore sous
les normes pierres tombales que
constitue aujourd'hui les ruines de la
cité que de malheurs sur les visages de
ceux qui peuvent pleurer de joie comme
sur ceux qui ne peuvent plus pleurer à
force de désespoir
[Musique]
scopie et maintenant tu ne tombe 1500
morts les cercueils ont manqué il a
fallu creuser de longues fosses communes
où les victimes ont été ensevelies côte
à côte l'armée est arrivée est
maintenant que plus une plainte plus un
son de voix humaine ne sort des maisons
effondrées on a commencé le déblème
pendant que les bulldozers repoussent
les gravats le problème des hommes se
pose avec une acuité grandissante il y a
150 000 sans abris qui manquent de tout
de vivre dos de vêtements de couverture
on les voit autour de la ville dans les
parcs le long des routes installé dans
les débris de ce qui fut leur vie
attendre heure par heure jour par jour
une amélioration de leur terrible destin
car à ces 150 000 personnes il ne reste
rien et c'est peut-être le tableau le
plus déchirant de Skopje qui n'en manque
pas pourtant que la nuit qui tombe sur
ses groupes encore effarés d'horreur et
qui se refusent à recouvrir totalement
tous ses deuils toute cette misère et
jusqu'au silence de ceux qui n'ont plus
rien que leur courage et leur désespoir
[Musique]
temple de la révolution qui doit
s'accomplir dans l'agriculture française
nous est donnée dans la genêt ici comme
un beaucoup d'endroits le morcellement
abusif rendait non rentable 85% des
exploitations parce que trop exigus mais
ici à l'exemple des grandes propriétés
les agriculteurs ont réussi à créer en
des exploitations modernes qui peuvent
produire en grande quantité des qualités
valables pour l'exportation à l'échelle
de ce regroupement les vergers de la
Genèse sont devenus un exemple
l'entretien les traitements peuvent
s'opérer par moyen massifs le chef
d’exploitation peut avoir à sa
disposition les mêmes facilités qu'un
chef d'entreprise dans ses ateliers
l'interphone à sa place dans les vergers
comme à l'usine
allô allô
voulez-vous me préparer 75 pour ce soir
[Musique]
à cette échelle aussi l'association a pu
créer son propre centre météorologique
avec ballon sonde et radar qui permet
d'aménager les traitements en fonction
de l'évolution du temps
[Musique]
qu'un orage soit détecté un système
d'information rapide donne l'alerte aux
exploitations menacées qui peuvent
engager atteint la lutte contre les
nuées menaçants
[Musique]
la fusée par hagrène ira jusqu'à 3000
mètres inséminé le nuage et le dissoudre
sans danger pour la récolte
[Musique]
de même le groupement a pu se doter
d'une organisation de sélection et
d'impactage qui va trier les fruits et
préparer l'envoi de produits
parfaitement calibrés et non moins
parfaitement présenté
un service particulier créé par le
groupement reste en liaison avec les
divers marchés et établit
quotidiennement les cours en fonction
des informations qu'il en recueillent
ainsi armés pour lutter victorieusement
contre la concurrence le groupement sert
par wagon entier les clients aussi bien
à Londres ou à Bruxelles qu'à Paris
[Musique]
tout bien entendu ne part pas vers les
grosses agglomérations pour les produits
de moindre qualité les pionniers de
l'exploitation agricole ont trouvé une
formule le surplus se vend directement
sur les marchés de la région du
producteur ou consommateur voici donc un
essai concluant de l'organisation
agricole de demain en regard que
reste-t-il au solitaire inorganisé avec
le seul espoir du client de passage
[Musique]
cet hiver plus de cheveux crépus plus de
boucles la coiffure se met aux cheveux
lisses c'est la saison dira-t-on sans
sourire de la simplicité
et voici comment Madeleine place voit la
Parisienne de cet hiver
[Musique]
voici de son côté comment l'interprète
Thérèse Chardin dont le style nous
rappelle avec tout de même un petit goût
de twist l'impératrice Eugénie
cette tête sans boucle et sans vague
peut d'ailleurs fort bien s'accommoder
d'une perruque
chez Jacques de singes cette jolie tête
ronde qui rappelle la classique coiffure
à la Jeanne d'Arc se sommes Rav
volontiers d'un chignon Berlingo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous revenons alors à la
sophistication des grandes soirées
comme aussi chez leur cas dans les
larges bandeau accuseront le romantisme
d'un visa
chez votre coiffeur madame
[Musique]
muse ou backpack c'est toujours le même
instrument familier surtout au berger
des montagnes bindiou simple on le
trouve dans toutes les traditions
bretonnes on le trouve aussi simple avec
son unique cornet mais plus grave en
Bulgarie en Grèce dans les abruptes
on le trouve plus perfectionné avec
trois ou quatre chalumeaux dans les pays
celtiques Bretagne Irlande Écosse petit
orgue primitif qui garde dans ses
sonorités nasillardes le goût des Landes
à Fougères et des longues solitudes
ainsi la cornemuse peut s'enorgueillir
d'une très haute et très universelle
tradition mais c'est seulement depuis la
fin de la guerre que la cornemuse qui
commençait à se laisser oublier a vu
renaître son succès si les sonneurs de
Bretagne se chiffraient en 1943 à
quelques douzaines ils sont aujourd'hui
plus de 2000 de là ce rendez-vous de
Brest où l'on a vu quelques 3000
sonneurs de toute nationalités remplir
la rue de Siam d'un écho qu'elle
n'oubliera pas de sitôt
[Musique]
créez voici deux mois à Addis-Abeba
l'Organisation de l'Unité Africaine a
tenu sa première conférence à Dakar
le président de la République
sénégalaise a rappelé que dans sa grande
majorité l'Organisation de l'Unité
Africaine est composée d'État modérés
soucieux d'efficacité
[Musique]
la grève des marins est aujourd'hui
heureusement terminée c'en est fini pour
les Marseillais de voir le port encombré
de navires attendant un départ incertain
mais pendant des jours on a pu voir sur
les quais sur le pont des navires les
passagers embarqués pour la Corse et
pour l'Afrique du Nord obligé de
s'organiser pour vivre en attendant que
la grève s'arrête en présence de ces
difficultés le gouvernement a dû prendre
des mesures importantes pour mettre fin
à la situation précaire de ces milliers
de personnes il a donc dans ce sens fait
assurer les liaisons par la Marine
nationale et l'on a pu voir à Toulon les
matelots du croiseur de Grasse et dire à
l'embarquement des passagers qui
n'avaient jamais pensé être conduit à
bon port sous la volée des canons
mesure de circonstances qui aura permis
d'abréger l'attente et d'en finir avec
les heures pénibles des passagers en
souffrance il ne restera pour ses
passagers du de grâce que le souvenir de
journée perdue souvenir qui s'estompera
au cours des vacances en ce qui concerne
le fond du problème lui-même la sagesse
du personnel des compagnies a aidé
sûrement à sa solution raisonnable et
durable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien les vacances même pour l'ex
personnage divin qui était naguer
l'empereur du Japon aujourd'hui redevenu
un très simple humain en rupture de
travail quotidien de la villa au bord de
la mer qu'il habite pendant les vacances
il s'en va chaque jour avec
l'impératrice à la recherche de
spécimens nouveau de coquillages qu'il
destinent à ses travaux de laboratoire
on s'est en effet que l'empereur héroïto
est connu dans le monde scientifique
comme biologiste sans contrainte et en
famille tout pareil à un bon bourgeois
féru de sciences voilà l'empereur et
l'impératrice du Japon en vacances
[Musique]
vacances studieuses à l'ombre de
l'amphithéâtre romain de Nîmes
l'archéologie depuis quelques années est
à la mode et elle est même devenue une
distraction de choix pour les loisirs de
certains lycéens dans ce pays provençal
où les vestiges gagnent le Romain
surgissent partout il reste bien des
choses à découvrir la province est
encore pour longtemps un lieu de
fouilles intéressantes et nos jeunes
gens jouent avec beaucoup de conviction
à l'archéologue
précautionneux se conformant aux
méthodes de recherche éprouvées il passe
leur journée à la recherche d'un monde
disparu et chaque découverte est pour
une récompense
déjà la petite collection de trouvailles
s'accroît dans des proportions notables
elle constituera le premier fond du
futur musée de nageses dont il prospecte
l'oppidum et qui a déjà son conservateur
il va de soi que cette idée de musée
tourmente maintenant toutes les
cervelles et il n'est dans la région si
jeune vacanciers qui ne pense déjà avec
délectation à sa collection particulière
[Musique]
mis un service en 1821 le vieux pont de
Bordeaux entre les deux rives de la
Garonne près de son estuaire et devenue
avec la circulation moderne un lourd
souci sur le grand axe routier du Sud le
flot des voitures extrêmement abondance
il resserre obligatoirement
occasionnant bouchon et retard
Bordeaux construit donc un nouveau pont
suspendu à l'image de celui de
Tancarville auquel on accédera sur la
rive gauche par un viaduc d'accès dont
la longueur 871 mètres et double de
celui de Tancarville ces pilons de
porteurs dont les ancrages sont en cours
d'exécution s'élèveront jusqu'à 104
mètres contre 123 pour le pont normand
et le tablier surplombra de 53 m les
eaux de la Garonne laissant ainsi la
route libre au plus gros navire ce sera
l'un des plus beaux ouvrages du genre
construire est un devoir conserver en
états
Richelieu au confins du Poitou et de
l'Anjou reste aujourd'hui tel que le
construisit Armand du Plessis cardinal
de Richelieu Premier ministre de Louis
XII et grand homme d'État du château
celle qu'il avait voulu magnifique rien
ne subsiste qu'un pavillon des communs
le reste a été dépecé est vendu pierre
par pierre au début du XIXe siècle mais
excellente exemple d'urbanisme classique
la petite ville demeure debout
aujourd'hui classée en entier monument
historique et sa grande rue un peu trop
défigurée hélas par les vitrines qui se
sont élargies aux dépens des
architectures garde toujours sa grande
allure
le plan de restauration de Richelieu est
un effet en cours de réalisation et les
coins maltraités par les siècles ou par
les hommes se retrouveront dans quelques
années arraché à la vétusté et à la
ruine telles les halles avec leur
magnifique charpente véritable
chef-d'oeuvre d'assemblage remise en
étalant dernier Richelieu que la
fontaine appelait le plus beau village
de l'univers petit coin du patrimoine
national hier oublié est en voie de
renaissance
Notre-Dame démaquillée c'est une autre
œuvre de conservation et de
rajeunissement à laquelle on vient de se
livrer sur le portail central de
Notre-Dame de Paris dont on célébrait
voici de moi le huitième centenaire on
pouvait craindre les méfaits d'un
ravalement mais avec la méthode employée
le résultat est très encourageant
les siècles sans doute n'est surtout les
poussières et les fumées de notre temps
avaient accumulé une crasse épaisse
parfois de 3 cm
aujourd'hui le portail central retrouve
un relief imprévu et la suite des
vierges folles au milieu des démons
grimaçants qu'on revoit d'aujourd'hui
dans leur puissance d'expression
primitive nous ramène d'un seul coup le
goût vigoureux de ce Moyen-Âge qui suit
être à la fois énorme et délicat
[Musique]
pour les routiers professionnels qui
participent au Championnats du monde de
cyclisme à Renaix en Belgique c'est leur
h le favori numéro 1 l'homme abattre
c'est Rick van log
le voilà Rick van line avec son dossard
numéro 11
le début de la course ou la pluie se
déroule tambour battant avec plusieurs
tentatives d'échappées parmi ces
échappés celle de Henri Anglade du
Hollande et Dean et d'andrégade elle est
vouée à l'échec comme toutes les autres
vanloy veille au grain il Colma toutes
les brèches avec beaucoup de brio pas de
doute 20 live va gagner c'était prévu
mais attention regardez bien il y a une
faille dans le scénario le Belge bait ne
joue pas le jeu il bat le super champion
malgré les ordres reçus après un sprint
de tumultures il aurait peut-être mieux
valu pour batte qu'il ne soit pas
champion du monde mais ceci est une
autre histoire
[Musique]
Leipzig en Allemagne de l'Est a été
cette année le théâtre d'un grand
rassemblement de la jeunesse du monde
entier à l'occasion du 4e Festival du
sport et de la gymnastique
120 000 personnes ont assisté à cette
parade monstre
des heures durant athlètes et gymnastes
ont présenté les exercices chaudement
applaudis par les spectateurs
enthousiastes
plus de 20 000 jeunes gens et jeunes
filles ont participé au final de cette
grande fête de la jeunesse
et c'est sans doute parmi eux que l'on
découvrira les grands champions de
demain
[Musique]
assez lente bouddhiste et hindouiste ont
rendu hommage aux yeux catarragama après
s'être baigné dans les eaux du fleuve
sacré les fidèles ont célébré leur Dieu
selon des pratiques qui n'excluent pas
les séculaires clous plantés dans la
chair et les crochets piqués dans le dos
pendant deux semaines la foule des
fidèles se livrent à des danses et à des
réjouissances qui laissent libre cours à
leur enthousiasme religieux car le
peuple cingulaire est mystique manifeste
sa croyance de façon diverses et non
dénuée d'originalité les éléphants
Richmond arnacher prennent part à la
procession qui célèbre une croyance très
ancienne ainsi à ses lin les rythes
religieux se perpétuent à travers les
siècles sans rien changer
de dieux port à Zeebruges le mouvement
populaire flamand a manifesté par un
défilé automobile qui couvrait des
kilomètres et qui mêlaient les marques
et les cylindrées sont mécontentement de
voir la langue française dominée sur le
littoral sur son passage à hostende ce
cortège a été l'objet de contre
manifestations et la police a dû
intervenir à diverses reprises pour
maintenir l'ordre
flambée de la guerre linguistique qui
provoque des dissensions en Belgique des
huées et des acclamations des
bousculades et des explosions de pétards
ont marqué cette marche sur la côte qui
n'a fait sans doute ni l'affaire des
commerçants ni celle des touristes en
ville légiatures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'affaire du train postal Glasgow
Londres aura une place de choix dans les
annales du gangstérisque c'est en effet
le plus gros hold-up de l'histoire
criminelle les gangsters ont raflé plus
de 3 milliards et demi d'anciens francs
la police d'abord n'a plus que
reconstituer l'histoire comme dans les
meilleurs westerns les bandits ont
arrêté le train en pleine campagne
ligoter les postiers enlevez 109 sacs
postaux bourrés de billets de banque
bientôt pourtant enquête et ratissage
portaient leurs fruits on découvrait
l'affaire isolée ou les bandits avaient
ramené le butin et la fosse qu'ils
avaient creusé pour y faire disparaître
les sacs postaux et Scotland Yard
marquait un point important elle
arrêtait deux femmes et trois hommes et
récupérer 120000 livres provenant du
hold-up un blackout complet règne sur
ses inculpés dont l'interrogatoire
continue premier pas sur une piste qui
mènera on l'espère jusqu'au cerveau qui
organisa l'opération on le sait le crime
ne paie pas
[Musique]
on sait que à Copenhague comme
d'ailleurs dans le Danemark entier tout
le monde va à bicyclette le vélo s'il
n'est pas un sport national n'en est pas
moins une habitude nationale mais
l'abondance de ces transports
particuliers créent des problèmes
combien de vélo en rupture de parking ou
en contravention avec la loi or la loi
n'est pas tendre et voici tout
simplement ce qui arrive
et voilà tout ce qui peut se consumer
brûle allègrement
et quant au reste un passage à la presse
en fera sous une forme ou même un
cycliste chevronné ne reconnaîtrait pas
un cadre en fera un bloc d'excellente
ferraille et l'industrie du vélo car
tous enchaîne retrouvera de nouveaux
clients dont les bicyclettes un jour ou
l'autre mais il est inutile d'achever
[Musique]
à l'allongement des silhouettes imposées
par les couturiers pour la saison
prochaine les modistes ont répondu
d'accord et Jean Barthès il y ajoute des
ailes à mouvement chasseurs de coureurs
de prairies à développer en hauteur
toutes les calottes de ses créations
[Musique]
marie-Christiane qui met l'agréablement
velours feutre et fourrure passe
facilement du chasseur ravissant c'est
le mot au casque dit de Jeanne d'Arc
mais pourquoi Jeanne d'Arc
[Musique]
pour Georgette de 13 c'est la forme du
casque encore qui sert de base à
l'élégance de la saison et c'est une
prémonition dans ce triste été d'un
nouvel hiver rigoureux voici la toque de
fourrure irremplaçable finition d'une
élégance qui n'a pas peur de dire son
nom Alaska et son prénom Paris
[Musique]
est vide passe en rare magasin fermé
dans la rue des hertes un chien qui
ère abandonné c'est l'un des drames des
vacances
ils sont trop nombreux ceux qui au
moment du départ soucieux de ne pas
s'encombrer mais oubliez d'une affection
même ancienne abandonne sans complexe le
petit compagnon qui partagea un moment
de leur vie MUF le sans cœur ou égoïste
sans pitié
et chaque année revoit le spectacle de
ces bêtes qu'on laisse au hasard parfois
même en leur fermant la bouche d'une
bande de sparadrap pour éviter les longs
appels
on ne dira jamais assez l'intérêt de
l'oeuvre de charité rempli chaque année
à cette époque par la Société
protectrice des animaux qui dépêchent
ces équipes à travers la ville pour
retrouver ou prendre à domicile les
pauvres bêtes et leur assurer un asile
et la nourriture quotidienne
au refuge de Gennevilliers chiens et
chats retrouvent un peu de la chaleur du
foyer refusé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cette saison le refuge est plein plus
de 300 chiens plus de 200 chats y
attendent que la vie leur rende ce
qu'ils ont perdu
beaucoup d'ailleurs retrouveront par
bonheur la chaleur d'un foyer car chacun
peut venir ici chercher un compagnon le
cas des bêtes si cruellement abandonné
n'en est pas moins un drame drame de
l'égoïsme drame de la cruauté humaine
vous qui partez en vacances sont Jésus
[Musique]
les trains de vacances qui vivent les
grandes villes à l'époque du mois d'août
laisse au milieu des rues des peuplées
une race singulière d'hommes seuls les
célibataires du mois d'août les aousiens
on les voit à l'heure où leur travail
finit
errer nous Challans sans doute mais
saisis tout de même par les nécessités
quotidiennes auxquelles ils n'ont pas
généralement à faire face
[Musique]
grand problème de la houssien le
blanchissage il sentir généralement au
rayon lingerie d'un magasin c'est
coûteux mais facile et puis pense-t-il
ça servira toujours
[Musique]
chance curieuse là où si un me
recherche orange
d'accord plutôt le magasin
d'alimentation pour satisfaire
probablement à une funeste passion de
cordon bleu qui la réfréné toute l'année
là où sien c'est le client idéal pour
libre-service son sens pratique lui
réserve de grandes joies au rayon des
ustensiles ménagers
comment a-t-on pu se passer si longtemps
d'une pareil rap à fromage
[Musique]
naturellement il y a des déboires
tous ces menus soins du ménage aux
travaux ennuyeux et facile comme le
disait Verlaine crée sans doute une
œuvre de choix n'est qu'un apprenti de
génie n'est pas toujours de taille à
dominer
pour moins que cela va-t-elle se passer
son épée au travers du corps mais
monsieur Durand n'est pas Vatel si elle
a c'est complications la vie de là où
sien a ses joies les joies sévères du
devoir accompli que confirme le petit
mot trouvé sous la porte les autres se
paient du bon temps là-bas ici il est
seul aux prises avec la vie le beau rôle
est pour lui il se sent presque un héros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
razaville capitale de la République
congolaise vient d'être le théâtre de
graves incidents une manifestation
déclenchée au cours d'une grève générale
de protestation rapidement dégénéré et
c'est terminé par 200 glandes bagarre
les manifestants se sont heurtés aux
forces militaires congolaises qui
défendaient les abords de la prison où
le président Fulbert du loup avait fait
enfermer les leaders syndicaux
[Applaudissements]
5 morts et 12 blessés témoignaient de la
violence des accrochages de même que
l'incendie de la prison où il est
manifestants libéraires les prisonniers
[Musique]
ce premier acte était suivi d'un second
une foule évaluée à 5000 personnes
assiégaient le palais présidentiel
[Applaudissements]
lavé fulbergulu finissait par résigner
ses fonctions et il abandonnait bientôt
le palais présidentiel après avoir
transmis ses pouvoirs à l'armée un
gouvernement provisoire devait être
installé au cours de la nuit suivante
dirigé par Monsieur Masamba débat ancien
président de l'Assemblée il comprend
cette titulaires et ces données trois
mois pour régler la succession du
président Youlou dans le respect des
accords internationaux intérieurs
[Musique]
le président Diem a chargé les
militaires d'assurer sécurité et ordre
public contre les troubles fermentés par
l'organisation communiste du vietng dont
il accuse les bons de faire le jeu des
heures graves pour le Sud Vietnam
[Musique]
la flotte française vient d'être dotée
d'un porte hélicoptère premier bâtiment
de ce type en France à la fois porte
aéronef et croiseur anti-aériens la
résolu est également destinée à
remplacer sur toutes les mers du globe
le vieux Jeanne d'Arc comme croiseur
d'application de l'École navale
[Applaudissements]
il est équipé d'une piste d'un vol de
100 mètres et peut abriter 4
hélicoptères lourdes du type Super
Frelon ses appareils seront utilisés
pour la détection et le torpillage des
sous-marins
[Musique]
au crépuscule du 24 août Paris a fêté le
19e anniversaire de sa libération le
cortège officiel a remonté la scène
cette grande rue de Paris sous les ponts
embrasés jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville ou une
foule considérable s'était rassemblée
atendant les chars de Leclerc qui
rapportaient de la gare Montparnasse le
fanion du libérateur
[Musique]
c'est ce fanion qu'en présence de la
Maréchal Leclerc le ministre des Anciens
Combattants Monsieur Jean Saint-Denis
devait remettre au président du conseil
municipal relique précieuse qui témoigne
de la journée historique ou Paris
retrouve à sa liberté et sa fierté
ce petit tour de devoir de vacances nous
a conduit d'abord à Pont-l'Évêque sur
Oise où se déroulait le championnat de
France de joute sur l'eau vieux sport
dont l'origine remonte à l'occupation
des troupes romaines qui avait pris goût
à ce jeu lors de leur campagne d'Égypte
depuis il n'a jamais cessé d'être
populaire
reste et le vainqueur comme au Moyen-Âge
peut s'enorgueillir non seulement
d'avoir rompu quelques lance mais encore
d'avoir démonté l'adversaire et laver
son honneur
rando
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la côte basque ne détrônera sans doute
pas demain Hawaii ni melbour nous prie
naissance ce sport magnifique qu'on
nomme le surfing et dont Biarritz abrite
le championnat d'Europe
une planche munie d'une dérive voilà
tout l'outillage ajoutez-y une bonne
pratique de la natation et des qualités
de courage et d'adresse et vous pouvez
être le champion des surfeurs il s'agit
de se rendre au large et de se laisser
alors porter au rivage sur la crête
d'une vague c'est tout mais on mesurera
la qualité du spectacle la qualité de
l'exploit
les images disent mieux que les mots la
beauté de ce sport implantés depuis peu
en France mais qui compte déjà des
centaines d'adeptes
[Musique]
c'est du côté de chez Dior que nous
sommes allés chercher la ligne de la
saison la collection créée par Marc born
affirme le retour au vrai tailleur
jupe veste et blues souvent d'ailleurs
agrémenté d'un cache-nez
[Musique]
jaquette appuyait et souvent étiré
boutonné oh jupe droite ou appli plat
notons une prédominance du style
chemisier
[Musique]
les manteaux parmi lesquels apparaissent
quelques somptueuses imperméables sont
dessinés sans ampleur excessive mais la
carrure le col et les manches se sont
développées épaules large et silhouette
droite telles sont les mots d'or
les robes possèdent des encolures
importantes montantes et la carrure est
accentuée
[Musique]
pour l'après-midi pour le cocktail le
tailleur de dentelle fait son apparition
il fait beau ménage avec ses robes
droites de ligne simple à l'encolure
dégagée
[Musique]
la robe du soir impose le style de la
saison long fourreau de ligne sinueuse
dont le décolleté montant sur la gorge
mais échancrés dans le dos peut
s'accompagner de longue manches et
souvent d'un boléro orfèvré de broderie
et de cabochon voici le bel hiver du
côté de chez Dior
[Musique]